I'm Bruce Ferguson Dean of the School of
the Arts and this panel is entitled from
novel to dramatic presentation the
history of the journey from printed from
printed page to dramatic presentation
whether from a screenplay to the screen
or a book in this case to the stage is
filled with fraught stories in which
writers bemoan the losses of words
directors and producers fire writers and
Cavalier style and actors try to serve
these many masters simultaneously just
as in reading interpretation is the name
of the game each movement from one media
to another is a journey of translation
and as we all know the Latin root of
translation is exactly the same as the
Latin root for traitor
so with us today happily to discuss this
translation ii of salman rushdie's books
to reach the stage the first was Haroon
the sea of stories we have two of the
culprits one who was complicit in his
own translation and we also have an
experienced drama to tease out this
particular story we have Jaime cousin
curator of Midnight's Children
humanities festival itself a former
president of literary managers and drama
turks for the americas jamie was on the
theatre Faculty of Boston College and
the Boston University Theatre School she
was also the treat the chief drama Turk
and literary manager of the Huntington
Theatre and Jamie will moderate secondly
we have Simon Reid on my far left one of
the three adapters of Midnight's
Children for the stage Simon was the
Royal Shakespeare Company's drama turd
and he is at present the artistic
director of the Bristol Old Vic Simon
has acted as drama turgon producer on
many important works in Britain
including but not limited to Hamlet love
in a wood The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe and has worked with Tim supple
previously on tales from Ovid and
finally we have mr. Salman Rushdie
himself
Salman is the author of eight novels the
most recent of which is the new
york-based fury which I highly recommend
too if you haven't read it he has also
published three works of nonfiction and
his awards include the Booker Prize and
then the Booker of Booker's the best
novel Midnight's Children to have won
the Booker in its first 25 years in
introducing with pleasure these three
guests I would like to particularly
thank Salman Rushdie for his generosity
and working so closely with Columbia
University and giving of his valuable
time to these many events so please join
with me in welcoming
Jimmy cousins Simon Reid and Salman
Rushdie
those of you who were in the last
session know that the discussion ranged
very widely we're going to range widely
as well but we're going to telescope it
to the process from the novel Midnight's
Children to the stage adaptation which
is here in New York opened last night
and has seemed to other audiences before
this first in London and then in Ann
Arbor Michigan
and we're going to start by raising the
question of how much does one need to
know before seeing the play I heard that
in London someone left the theater and
said wow I never knew the difference
between India and Pakistan until now so
so the first question I have for two out
of our three collaborators the third
who's who's rehearsing the show uptown
at the Apollo for the press
opening Tim supple the director is how
did you set about presenting the play
and and forming the adaptation with a
sense of how much people needed to know
before coming in someone you want to
jump in first and then will the English
language is a help but I think you know
other than that our basically our
assumption was that people we could not
assume that people would know anything
at all and in that in that respect it
should be like any other play let's say
you go and see the new play by whoever
you know the new Edward Albee play the
new Arthur Miller play and you Tom
Stoppard play all you know is what is
put onstage in front of you you know and
and you respond to it as an audience you
know in those terms you're not expected
to have gone to university first you
don't expect it to show up and and our
view was exactly that that we should
assume that people would come knowing
nothing expecting nothing except what we
offered them and that the what we offer
them should be completed it so in terms
it should be complete as a traumatic
experience in terms of telling the story
it should have whatever historical and
cultural information that you needed to
understand the play it should be there
in the work you know it shouldn't be
extraneous to it so
I mean that was I think we we worked
hard to make sure that that story did
tell itself I mean really right through
the process even after we'd finished
rehearsals I mean the previews the
previews of the play in London we went
through that and try if we talked to the
audience after it came out certainly I
did and I'm sure Simon did as well and
trying to find out how they'd been
responding and if there were things that
needed clarifying and you know we added
things here and subtracted things there
and you tried to make sure the story was
being clearly told so no I mean all you
have to do is buy a ticket we also we
knew it already worked as a story
because because the novel has been quite
successful I think in the last 20 odd
years and the the most important thing I
saw and says is that it did work as a
player actually there were a couple of
moments in in the early previews where
it wasn't quite working as a play so
that we did we did take out stuff that
basically wasn't dramatic that was kind
of it was very interesting or it was um
it was presenting some interesting
character aspects but it didn't sort of
up the sakes or do all those things that
dramas need to do to keep you hooked in
the theatre so it was so I think it's it
is important that's yeah there will be
people who come who have read the novel
obviously and that do know a bit about
the history and the Pakistani government
must be very pleased and our people have
gone away knowing about Pakistan from
this version of Pakistan in the flavours
but that you don't need to know about
Rushdie and you don't need to know about
about the book or the history to enjoy
it and enjoy in the same way as as when
the novel came out it was a it was a
breakthrough novel it kind of taught
people both about this this about this
amazing kind of writing this Rushdie
writing and it also taught people about
a period of kind of colonial and
postcolonial history that they wouldn't
necessarily have known otherwise and it
introduced kind of into literature Eden
Europe and literature in in in North
America
I kind of a kind of work that people
hadn't seen or heard or read before and
I think the play will probably do the
same again I'd be really interested to
see how many how many people in the
audience are from the Indian community
you know I mean I'm interested to see
how many of you are here which is nice
and I hope they'll be similarly a lot of
people in the audience who will bring
that kind of other knowledge you know
into the into the show and clearly
that's me the thing from the moment the
book came out that the way in which
people from India or Pakistan or people
who knew about that world responded was
a little different you know then then
then the Western responsive when the
book came out the Western response the
book tended to be in terms of responding
to the more fantasy elements the books
the more the more kind of surrealistic
fabulist elements of the storytelling in
India when it first came out people kind
of reviewed it as a history book I've
always worked one of the favorite
remarks anybody ever made to me about my
work was soon after the book came out I
was in India and I did a event like this
in Bombay and a man came up to me
afterwards he said you know I could have
written your book I know all that stuff
you know which I took as I took as a
great compliment because you know he was
talking about sharing an experience that
he felt at a more academic level
professor homi Bhabha will be well known
to many of you here Bernie was when we
were all much younger he was teaching it
at Sussex University England and invited
me down there to do one of the first
readings I ever did anywhere and who are
we introducing it
Herbies style is sometimes a fake and he
that he said but the thing that he liked
so much about Midnight's Children is
that it was a novel in which one felt
that one was also somehow the author of
the book something which he gave I took
as a kind of compliment but his students
were less impressed and and after the
Q&A session at the end of it the first
question was actually the student
observers and actually my first question
is not for mr. Eastley but for dr. bhava
and could he explain in what sense he is
the author of midnight homi Bhabha was
here two weeks ago at the festival
talking about Bombay and he was he was
not opaque he's an old friend so I
collage I know you talked a little bit
something about how in previews you had
to take certain things out that were not
clear that were opaque that then it had
to be clarified um and I want to ask
what more questions about that later
people very interested about you know
creative conflict you have three
adapters you have actors you have a lot
of people who probably have their own
opinions but before we go to that I'm
interested in in beginning at the
beginning I mean how did this all come
about I mean who was approached I guess
it began in a way
four years ago or so when Tim saw Paul
the director and I were involved in
another project Tim did a version of my
book Haroon in the sea of stories at the
National Theatre in in London and and on
that occasion I mean I thought it was a
wonderful adaptation and and that made
me interested to work with him again on
that occasion I was not involved in
doing the adaptation and somebody else
did it and I just went along to the show
and kind of loved it and so anyway four
years passed and then Tim got in touch
with me now in connection with the Royal
Shakespeare Company and said that they
had asked him to ask me if there was
something else that we might do together
and initially I think the project that
was proposed was that we might make a
version of Alice in Wonderland and which
I didn't really want to do because I
felt a lot of people could do that and
there's no particular reason why I
should I mean I like how I said
Wonderland as well as the next person
which is you so if you'll find out your
viewers very very true but and then the
way the conversation developed was that
I had I said that there was this unused
script that I had written for Midnight's
Children when they had been a BBC
project to make a five-part miniseries
about the book and I had started in this
five-hour dramatization
and I said well say you know there is
this dramatized version in existence and
sure you know it's television and you'd
have to rethink it for the stage but
after all a lot of it is just scenes you
know in scenes the scenes and so I said
why don't you all look at that and see
if you feel that the TV version could be
the basis of a staged version and then
it went over to the RSC where Simon was
still then the dramaturg and then he and
Adrian Noble who was then the artistic
director and Tim and all everybody had a
look in it and it was really on the
basis of that that we have we decided to
go forward I don't know if you want to
talk about what
at the RSC yeah that's right because
some when well well Tim was site Kenya
than that he because he came to us and
said you know the National Theatre are
really interested in doing Midnight's
Children and so and so the eye receives
said right we'll have that will them say
that that was actually quite clever kind
of politics I think and there was also I
think it was also there was another
great theater director Sir Peter Hall he
was also interested in in doing it
because his son Chris Hall had been one
of the producers on the but but then you
say to responsible people at you know
yeah we should do didn't I saw them
before him before the National tea and
Adrian said well I love it but it's a
big no-no if you're going to put that
big book onto stage what was wonderful
was this calling card of this of this
screenplay of this fire of the Sun says
I think about five-and-a-half hours it's
no it's 5 10 minutes it's it was an
initial episode of 90 minutes followed
by 450 min 50 minute episodes so if you
add that all up it's actually 10 minutes
under 5 hours so it's just it's just
some if I took slightly longer than 5 to
read me but but we but we but the
screenplay I mean that and then and then
also everybody could read that and
people in it and novel takes it takes a
long time to read and when you're in the
theater the reason you work in the
theater so you don't want to read
Dickens novels and you don't wonder you
don't want to read middle marchings out
you just want a nice three-hour little
package and so that was a great help and
but then for Tim and me and Salman what
was great is that we were able to look
at we have these two primary sources we
had the screenplay in which things
already changed things have been left
out decisions had been being made and we
had the novel to go back to where the
guy had done the screenplay had cocked
up and actually he'd left really good
things that out after the novel and he
should be more faithful to the original
novelists I have to say Salman wrote the
screenplay as well
and then and then when you get then you
get onto the play it was fantastic
because the person who could you could
be totally unfaithful to the original
writers intention was Salman and you
could sort of say things I only don't
want that bit that's kind of long and
boring and and that won't work onstage
and there's this kind of really
interesting
we're not friction but sort of a way
that these three things kind of melded
together
it's the screenplay the stage play and
the original novel and the original
novel of course as well is although it
comes out of Salmons mind is a version
of myths and realities and unrealities
and histories and politics and all sorts
of stories that are already already
there so it's kind of an adaptation or
an adaptation of an adaptation which is
actually what really really good writing
is in the end but also I think it's true
to say that the often Tim and Simon were
more faithful to the original book than
I was and I was saying as you say I
think that he'll about you know cut that
change that don't like her and they
would say very screw fiercely going back
in and ferreting out particular
paragraphs to the novel and saying look
here's a bit that we really shouldn't
lose as these are good sentences and
let's put those back in here etc in a
very very detail that it almost
paragraph by paragraph way that was I
mean kind of in a way refreshed my
knowledge of the book that I've written
so long ago to see how these individual
sentences were striking the two of them
and and we almost never quarreled I
should say Tim Tuffle who's not here
that's because he didn't do anything
really know the teleplay was not without
its own politics of controversy yeah you
wrote you wrote it in 1993 it was
published in 1999 even though it never
actually seen the screen and in your
introduction you write that what
happened during the shooting of that
telothane and obviously it failed I mean
it never came to be what signaled your
your break with the east well it just it
was a dreadful I mean it was in those
bad years when all sorts of things went
wrong no for me and what happened is
that we didn't actually have a film any
of it we got that close to filming I
mean we got about 10 days away from
principal photography so it was kind of
heartbreaking to have it cancelled at
that 11th hour and 59th minute you know
because the first thing that happened is
that India refused us permission to film
which is a difficult thing about India
and we managed to solve that problem by
relocating the shoot to Sri Lanka which
was very happy to have us and in many
ways it was almost a better location
because Bombay today doesn't really look
like Bombay then you know if you want to
look at that pre high-rise Bombay of the
1950's it's actually quite difficult to
find it now and a lot of the sorts of
locations we were looking for or in many
ways easier to find in Sri Lanka it's
also quieter and so on and and anyway we
were we were had the full support of the
government and so on and said we got
very close to starting and then they
were political upheavals there and
essentially the government changed its
mind and as I say from having told us
there is no problem
come over here make your film go ahead
ten days before we started filming they
get a hundred percent reverse and said
you know you've got a we
to get out of the country so it was
shattering you know and very upsetting
for many pairs of fully cast production
you know we had it was fully designed we
had all the locations found we were
ready to go so it was a it was a plane
crash you know it was like a plane
crashing taking off and crashing at the
end of the runway you know and
heartbreaking for the actors involved
and and and and for me I mean as for
many writers would say that the worst
thing of all is wasted work you know you
spend all this time and you've got this
thing sitting there and it doesn't
what's the script you everybody said it
was a good script but so what you know I
mean what's the script that doesn't have
a film and I think actually many ways
the one person in the story we haven't
mentioned is my British paperback
publisher Caroline Michele who did this
incredibly generous thing she said we
will publish this script even though
there is no film so they published a
paperback book of the screenplay that
had no screen you know and really it was
that paperback book that her Simon said
became our calling card we could show it
to people and say look at works and and
instead of reading a three hundred
thousand word novel they could read this
script and it would show them that it
worked and so that that's the other part
of the puzzle you know that allowed it
to come into being and then we just did
it over he was in a year and a half it
took yeah which sounds like a long time
isn't it 18 months but that was actually
because in three people most the time on
three separate continents all doing all
doing other work at the same time but
also there's a kind of it needs to be
that long gestation here and I think
didn't it we sort of we fired back
drafts back and forth by by email
couldn't have done it without email this
is this entirely depended on being able
to attach documents to
otherwise you can just imagine fax
machines churning out endless traffic
impossible and I'm Tim and eyes the
first thing that we did was we kind of
did a sort of cut and paste between well
of the of the screenplay and as sam says
you know the best bits from from the
novel that we thought should should go
back in and then we asked and then which
Salman commented on and then also be our
Salman to write new bits so there are
completely new bits that appear on stage
and new new events that have never
appeared in Midnight's Children in any
of its other fullness before so there's
and some which are there's one very
early in the play there's a moment which
is in the novel but with different
dialogue at the moment were where the
grandfather and his wife the Salim's
grandfather his newlywed bride I'm
making love for the first time and he
asks her to move and she doesn't know
what he means and is they were not
disgusted when she finds out what he
means and she says to him you know
husband or no husband I'm not the moving
type and this in the show is always but
it's one of the guaranteed laugh lines
it's always a big laugh line and she
does it wonderfully well but it's not in
the book I mean that's the line that was
just that I mean I think it's in the TV
version but I think I came up with it at
some later point and now I wish I
thought of it in time
and there's also a line that you added
just before the press night where this
rediculous change happens where a guy
jumps in a basket in in Bangladesh then
he comes out of the basket and he's back
in Delhi and and see it as an audience
you go well that's the great thing about
having the Padma character as the
representative of the audience but she
could say what the hell is this you know
what kind of nonsense of a story is this
you get into a basket in one country you
get out of it in another country and and
he this is a piece of magic brought
about by the character of Parvati the
witch who after all is supposed to be a
sorceress and he's able to say what she
really was
and it's a it's such an absurd kind of
piece of foot spa you know that because
it's just say yes it's impossible so on
you know and the audience immediately
laughs and therefore forgives you you
know it becomes kind of complicit with
what you've done
yeah that's not that was what you were
talking about having to cut things even
in the preview process but simply we
found that the second act there was a
chunk of it which wasn't really working
it just needed to go and it was like a
15-minute chunk we were taking out of
the story which meant unfortunately that
we had to get from here to there
somehow because all the linking material
had just been cut out and so we had to
make up a scene which was that scene
when when we adapt from a non dramatic
piece of literature in this case novel
to dramatic one often directors talk
about through line or spine or one
dramatic action with arc of the play
these things that that so that all that
all the beads on the necklace gets
strung together and so that you were
talking about the broken mirror in the
last session can't really get away with
that often on stage
you really can't and that's something I
think you can in a novel that you cannot
when you're dealing with dramatic
material at the end of the day there
needs to be some unity some action
something driving that in a sense even
if it doesn't feel like it hangs
together makes it all hang together
something I don't know if you agree with
that or not but I know I've read that
one of the through lines that you've
come up with were really not one but
three that it was the tale of a Muslim
family the tale of a particular period
in the Indian subcontinent continental
history and in the 20th century and the
tale of one man three adopt three
adapters and three through lines how did
you manage to make that all weave
together sort of felt like a unified
whole well the thing is is that I mean
you said you know making that transition
for something that isn't dramatic into a
dramatized form actually the wonderful
thing about the novel is that it is
dramatic it is written it's even it I
mean it uses many languages but one of
the languages that are very
self-consciously uses is the language of
film and Bombay film vocabulary and it
actually has a completely natural arc
with right in the middle somebody gets
born and it starts 32 years before the
moment he's born and it ends on his as
he goes into his 32nd year so it happen
oval that the story already has that arc
and it is part soap opera part history
part one it opens I was born in the city
of Bom Bom Bay once upon a time it
starts off as a as a story and in fact
it starts as a very very simple
production on stage where Zubin the the
man playing and the actor playing
selling just sits at the middle of the
stage it's completely empty and he says
those says those words so it so actually
that you know get the string of beads
thing or or getting the whole kind of
art it that wasn't difficult because
because that was already that already
there in the novel and I think the
slightly more tricky thing is that of
course an audience can can work two or
three times faster than you do when
you're reading a novel yourself and when
you've got something that is essentially
linear
narrative and you know that you're going
to be jumping on and you're gonna you're
gonna end up seen and that sort of stuff
is that actually you have to you have to
keep on your keep on your toes and keep
keep having diversions and things so
that people don't lose interest so they
don't just like Padma keep asking so
what happened next what happened next
you know they need to know the kind of
the texture and the detail and that was
where actually having a director as one
as one of the adapters was very very
interesting because in a sense the stage
directions became as him sometimes as
important as the dialogue he had already
worked out with the designer merely
still that they were going to have a big
screen on stage
partly suggested by the screenplay
partly because it can be used literally
to place the action against the backdrop
of history of archive footage but also
to use it as a dramatic tool in itself
and that because that's written into the
script and that was written before we
even went into into rehearsals and
that's directorial that drives the
action as well yeah I think that it
tombs is a wonderfully collaborative
director and also a great maker of
images on stage and even this make maker
of I mean what in movies would be called
measles and you know he's just very good
at making making you see pictures that
mean things on stage so yeah I mean I
guess he did do a bit
we call it missile so he said there's a
there's a there's a story that I once
heard Tom Stoppard tell about the role
of staging in bringing a plate of life
even a great play I mean he used the
example of having scene of production at
Oxford of Shakespeare's Tempest and it
had been staged in the open air in
Oxford College with a with the stage was
so constructed that there was a lake
behind the stage that the audience was
looking the stage in behind that there's
a pond and the director had constructed
and invisible just below the surface of
the lake a trestle runway going across
the lake so that at the end of the play
when Prospero finally release his aerial
from his captivity aerial runs and it's
dusk right so the light level is low and
you cannot really see the light Prospero
releases of an aerial runs flat-out for
the water and there's a moment at which
the audience realizes that he can't stop
he's going too fast to stop and then
amazingly he runs across the surface of
the water and disappears into the into
the dusk you can't see the other side of
the lake the director is positioned a
stagehand
with a firework in a bottle to light and
so as Ariel disappears across the lake
this firework goes off as aerial
basically runs into the dog runs across
the lake and this to the sky and as Tom
Stoppard said if you read Shakespeare's
play at this point it says exit Ariel
you know so even Shakespeare you know
can be helped by staging which he
probably knew which is why he left it
that open yes and are there examples of
that Mis production of where language
doesn't tell the story about the amis on
sand the staging does I think it's a
it's an amazing it's a piece of ensemble
acting in which the creation of worlds
on stage you know by this this group of
actors I mean you wouldn't believe the
mayhem that goes on backstage while
they're changing costumes all the time
to play all these different roles and
you're getting when you see the player
you think you're watching a cast of 100
people and and a lot of people who've
seen the play then see that 20 people
line up at the end and I think what
that's all where did everybody go and
it's it is the collective staging of the
creation of of different worlds to play
it habits a lot of different places and
locations cetera and they come amazingly
to life in each place my viewing I was
just gonna say that actually also what
is wonderful about having that cast of
20 very experienced actors is that and
particular doing it in the context of
the Royal Shakespeare Company is that
the language because even though there
is loads of Muse on sin and there is
some you know some fabulous designs but
by merely and lovely costumes everything
actually that the language actually
holds so much of it together as well and
with the experience of that cast is that
I mean silently only said all you need a
lot you and your needs knowledge of
English to come and come and see this
actually you don't really even need
needed knowledge of English because this
the sound that apart from the fact there
are other languages spoken in it it's
the sound of it and the and the the
richness of it kind of works beyond just
that the level of level of meaning I
think and that's and actually you know
in it's always difficult to or
embarrassing when you when you compare
writers to Shakespeare but actually one
of the great things about Rushdie as a
writer is he's a very Shakespearean
writer both in terms of his his themes
and his canvas but also in the fact that
he uses this amazing range of language
from
very high poetry to the language of the
street to the pastiche of of films and
advertising slogans and Suffolk and all
of all of that actually that that paints
the pictures as well through the
language just the Shakespeare paints his
pictures and through language too but
it's one of the great things about
working with the great British theater
company is the seriousness with which
actors which with everybody in the
company approaches the text you know
that the text is not just a starting
place you know I mean there's one actor
and I'm not going to say which one who
had a little trouble with learning lines
and therefore it was always pretty
interesting what he was going to come up
with on a given night let's say he's
still doing it
there particularly there's two moments
in the play where he clearly disapproves
of the lines that were written for him
to say and so he says something
different every night and I mean I wait
to see last night and I thought oh
haven't heard those nights
there are actually four adapters there's
the actor and then there are three of us
so why tell you the story respect for
language and this is the one exception
you know yeah but that you know I
remember more than once seriously
sitting in the rehearsal rooms while Tim
and the cast were going into the detail
of the language - with a degree of
penetration that was kind of the most
interesting seminar I've ever heard on
my writing you know and it was kind of
humbling to see Tim would say repeatedly
look at the sentences look at how
they're written you know don't you see
there sometimes there look them three
little short sentences don't run them
together there are three little short
sentences say them that way you know and
that degree of attention to exactly how
it's written you know and that it's not
written like that because the write it
wasn't to thinking about it but assuming
that paying the right of the compliment
of giving him the same degree of
attention you would give to a
Shakespeare soliloquy you know I you
assume the writer doesn't know what he's
doing and that he's done it like that
because it would be wrong if it were not
like that you know and therefore say the
lines as written you know and that is a
I think it's a British it's a great
richness of the British theatre that
there is that degree of seriousness it's
still a righteous theatre you know it's
a it's not a director's theatre it's a
righteous theatre and and that makes it
for a writer amazing to work in because
of that the seriousness with which your
work is taken I think the problem also
that was fantastic that there is theatre
this does still exist like that because
a lot of those actors and actually
indeed the actor who
who has problems with the lines that
they've worked so much in television
with a lot of the writing is just crap I
mean I know that because I've worked a
lot a lot in Italian you spend most of
your time on it on a television script
it's kind of it's because they're
written by committee you kind of you
hire and fire the writer you sometimes
three or four different writers on the
same script and then the whole thing
kind of gets gets rewritten by the by
the actors and the director actually
while it's being shot and so that kind
of lack of respect for writing on the
one hand in everybody's kind of working
life these very same actors are then
coming and that it's a kind of weird
schizophrenia they must live as that
actually but the thing about the you
know the context the RS are a CEO or a
company like that is that it just it
does give them that well if they're
working with the director like Tim and
also say if they've got a drama
turnaround as well because obviously
that is a that doesn't always happen in
in production but if you've got you've
also got somebody in there playing the
role of kind of protecting the integrity
of the writer then I think that's sort
of that that feeds into the respect that
particularly this writing deserves one
of the sessions in the humanities
festival this Wednesday is to bring
members of the company around the table
for the public to show them just how
meticulous they are it's an open
personal on Wednesday night that's a
plug officially I do think American
actors who are especially trained in
Shakespeare approach things that way but
we've learned a lot from the RSC I mean
from all the visits that have come here
and to that for that kind of precision
and meticulousness with the language
well since we're digging dirt anyway
about actors who aren't memorizing lines
or one in particular is there other dirt
I mean whether whether
you you opened it so you've got three
collaborators you've got a novelist very
well-known novelist sitting in the rooms
written a remarkable book you've got the
actors 20-strong director artistic
directors what were some of the
conflicts that came up can you give some
examples of some of the hurdles the
obstacles or some of them just
out-and-out fisticuffs that occurred
while you were making this work it's
kind of amazing the bear on the same
stage really we don't really talk to
each other it's like the Everly Brothers
like Simon and Garfunkel no actually I
was there was a point at which I was
almost worried that we weren't arguing
more because I think it's a process by
which you find out what you're doing is
too you know sometimes it's because you
don't have exactly the same view of it
strongly enough yeah we just agreeing
all the time to disagree I mean we did
get on get on like a house on they
disagree there were and one was one was
actually very simple one which was over
the length and there was because there's
you know when you take a piece of work
like this and your work in the theater
you say well shall we do this as a
trilogy or shall we do it's one of those
wonderful big events that starts at five
o'clock in the afternoon and goes on
till half 11:00 at night and has no
interval but we've all endured it and we
feel better because of it and actually
and and Tim Tim and I that particularly
felt that in this in the spirit of the
book and the kind of the sloppiness of
the story and the fact that we don't
want to you know have a drink before
they close the bars in England that
actually three hours conv Albert rarely
taken out of it
tucked out of the air three hours
including including an interval live if
possible was kind
for this and that quite and there was a
moment actually would last time I was in
New York with with Salome we haven't
finished that description I was talking
to someone and saying I think I think
tomorrow I want to make it a bit shorter
and someone if you make it any shorter
it will cease to be Midnight's Children
and that was I mean I wasn't a we didn't
have a fight or anything but that was a
particular moment where actually we did
have just Tim and I had to sort of
rethink we think that the fact that
maybe we were condensing it so much and
compressing it so much that we actually
we were reducing it and reducing it so
that it just became a kind of edited
highlights of you know all the best bits
difficult because you know when we
started the TV miniseries the original
project had been for seven our
adaptation and then that have been
boiled down to five which was the
version that I left that everybody saw
so and it had seemed to be very very
difficult to get it into five hours and
then the idea of taking two more hours
out of it for a long time just seemed
impossible and we also there was also
kind of degree of uncertainty about how
long it really was going to be you know
that when we when we had something not
that far away from the script as it's
now as it now exists and we showed it to
people some people said it was three
hours long and other people said it was
four hours long and they didn't seem to
be any clearer agreement about how long
it would take to to play this script
until we actually started doing it but
again in the in the event watching it in
its later stages of rehearsal and it's
early stages of previews it in a way
became quite clear that the three hour
could have pretty arbitrarily chosen but
the three hour limit was in fact pretty
close to the audience's tolerance level
you know how much can you expect your
audience to take in in the course of one
evening and I thought we all I think
felt that we were really at the linear
of what we could expand from our
audience and as I say if we in fact
thought we were over the limit and in
the case of the previews we took out 15
or 20 minutes of playing time in order
to bring it I mean now it's two acts of
about an hour and 25 minutes each to the
playing time is actually two hours and
50 minutes and then there's an interval
so it ends up being sort of three hours
and 10 I guess but but 20 minutes of
that is is a rest but there was another
key point where again we didn't have a
fight but actually email wasn't helpful
in this point because the thing about
email is that it can get a bit
impersonal and and there was and we sort
of reached to kind of a bit of a dead
end on a discussion that we were having
and it was great so we will ended up
having Athiya take away a takeaway meal
from the 3 monkeys it was called Tim's
house and that and we and we thrashed
out that what and the reason we've got
to this position is because the novel is
written in three books in three parts
now we originally did that the first
draft we did a bit was was in three
parts which would therefore have had two
intervals and would have therefore had
less time on stage but more time in the
theater and also there's that kind of
the artistic director Adrienne Noble the
previous artistic flair to the RSC
described the dissatisfaction of
something in three parts is that however
fantastic you're you've got this
wonderful carpet once you roll it up
it's gonna sag in the middle if you've
got if you've got three parts and so we
thought well okay but how let's try and
do it in two parts now that makes it
slightly awkward because actually the
great climax to the in the book and
really the great climax in the play that
the middle point of the play is where
the protagonist is born but then we had
this sort of section afterwards that we
wanted to do up until the interval if we
in two parts and rather in a kind of
vandala sztyc devil-may-care way I
suggested that we cut and I made the
mistake here suggest that we cut purely
for practical reasons not for any
intellectual or automatic reasons
whatsoever but just for pragmatic
reasons to get 10 minutes if not 15
minutes after the script of one of the
most key moments that happens in it
which is where Salim literally runs into
history
where he runs into the language marches
and says and makes up a sort of silly
little rhyme that they then go off and
have the first language riots - and it's
a fantastic moment in the novel it's a
brilliant kind of metaphor for the whole
thing and it works very very well on
stage and I very stupidly said we've got
to cut this bit because otherwise this
two-part thing went work and when it
gets to the interval in time and and
that actually was quite a robust great
helpful argument there was it was I said
no I mean the reason it's the reason
it's a difficult thing to cut is because
you know the novel in its simplest way
is a is normal about somebody who has
this absurd conceit about himself that
he is responsible for history and that
everything that happened happened
because of him and that and that from
the smallest things to the biggest
things as you go through the story in
the later stages story he his life
collides very directly with great
historical events and then you know you
as the reader or as the audience can can
judge to what degree he's telling the
truth into what degree it's just
obviously not true that he's in fact not
the master of his times but the victim
of them you know that that question
about the relationship of the individual
and the history of his times you know is
sort of what the plays about and and
this see in the scene of the language
man
it's really it's the first moment in the
story at which he actually collides with
history and it's it's at a smaller scale
what happens later in the book is on a
bigger scale but it's the prefiguring of
what's going to happen later and so to
remove it removes an important note in
the music you know without which I felt
that the story was really diminished so
and I mean I think wasn't just you know
Simon's being nice to say he was it was
wrong today without Tim 42 you know I
already had this I actually was as close
as he did get to fight but that's not
that that's because I've been sent this
list by count remembers from you or from
Tim of you know further stuff they
wanted to cut and change it was like 20
things you know some little some not
little and and when we got Rather's to
the table and Tim said well let's talk
about it what do you think about the
list I just had did the list and next to
everything it said no no no no forget
about it over my dead body
no maybe but unbowed snow so you know
that was by going in position and then
we sort of argued it I did in fact that
wasn't how it ended up but in fact I was
persuaded of the good sense of some of
the changes that were being suggested
and and and they were persuaded the good
sense of some of the things I was saying
and it was a pretty it wasn't an angry
discussion but it was very passionate
and it was with people all three of us
had really strong opinions but I don't
think anybody yelled at anybody or said
anything rude you know it was it was
friendly but well not in front of your
back
staiin story of my life but in a way
that was the the passion of conflict
that you were missing it was really
helpful yeah it was really magical and
it sharpened all of us I think in the
way in which we were thinking about the
text you know and and I think also it
did one thing for me which is I mean
having said that I have been from freest
with the adaptation you know in terms of
changing things I then I think went
through a stage where I became the least
amenable to changes you know and this
conversation and the various decisions
we collectively reached change that for
me and it actually made it possible for
me to do something that I thought I
would not be able to do which is that
once we actually started performing the
play that we would see things and say
that's not working and that I would be
prepared to change them no imagine
telling Harold Pinter that the third
seem doesn't quite work and we need to
lose it Harold you know I mean that
wouldn't work that I suddenly found a
way and I think it's because in a way of
the trust that the three of us had built
up in each other that we were actually
able to say look you guys gotta go and I
would say well yeah actually sort of
doesn't have to go doesn't it that
really so we made I think after that
conversation I think it actually made
something gel in the way in which we
were making the play and made things
possible after that which might not
otherwise it'd be time for one more
question and I wanted to spend a little
time we won't have it but we do want to
take some questions from the audience
about things other than creative
conflict which are other more difficult
conflicts such as the one that we're
involved in now
and politically and historically as we
confront history ourselves in this
country and around the world and the the
play what I loved about the adaptation
having seen it in the Barbican in
January was that it did not denude some
of the really brutal terrible aspects of
the novel I mean there was no sense of
soft selling it or should I just lose my
mind and I think about and and I love
that about the production especially
since we're doing performance for high
school students on Tuesday and we really
wanted to make sure that they were able
to confront that part of history and
that the play would do that now of
course that were at war and this is the
first time you're performing the
production with the world continually
changing every day how do you feel that
the production or the audiences have
received it given what's happening
currently well I think you mean amazing
actually one of the things I have to say
one of the things I'm proudest of about
the play is that it is it genuinely is
political theater in a way that I don't
think there's anything else that I do
about here I can't think of anything
else on the London stage that's that's
being as kind of ballsy political
theater its power and it reminds me of
the kind of plays that you know when I
was first thinking about writing and
theater that kind of plays what would
see in London and on the fringe and so
on in the late 60s and early 70s plays
by you know agitprop theatre companies
productions of you know plays about the
Vietnam War whatever it might be very
powerful direct political theater and I
think there parts of this play which
which I think more or less consciously
draw on that tradition of political
theater and I agree I'm glad we didn't
pull any of those punches and now I mean
just I'm saying talk about last night I
went to the performance last night which
is which is the first time it's been
played since there was actually a war in
Iraq and and the effect of what we all
the imagery
we are all now carrying around in our
heads because of what we're seeing in
the newspapers and on television the
effect of that or the audience's view of
the play is really very dramatic you
know that the the large section of the
second act which deals with the world
war you know which deals with not one
but two Wars of the period of tyranny
and so on you know there there's a scene
where there's a family waiting to die
while huge loads bombers fly overhead
and etc now I mean it's amazing to sit
there and look at that scene in the
light of what we know to be really
happening to families you know with
bombers flying overhead around the world
or in another part of the world so I
think it has it's been an amazing
coincidence that a play like this which
deals so directly with the subject of
war should show up but that precisely in
this moment right I mean I think it's
dreadful to say so but it may actually
help American audiences appreciate the
power of that part of the story because
after all otherwise it is dealing with
political events and wars from far away
and long ago you know but but in a way
this brings it brings it right into the
present tense I think there's another
aspect too I mean you talk about the
Khomeini fatwa breaking your picture of
the world and certainly we who live in
New York City in many ways have the
picture of our world broken since 9/11
so there's maybe even another layer in
watching that second part of the show
here in New York City that might be a
difference between the audiences I just
think you are saying that the great the
simple subject of the book has to do
with the relationship of the individual
and the great events of the times in
which we live you know to what extent
are we the masters or victims of our
times you know I mean that's that's the
question that
the story asks and that I think we all
ask and and one of the things that I've
always thought from the beginning of my
career as a writer which I'm still
exploring now is that the age in which
we live has removed what used to be a
comfortable distance between public
affairs and private lives you know that
that politics used to happen over there
and private life used to happen over
here and the degree of connection
between one on the other was often not
very great you know the example I've
often used about this is that you know
Jane Austen could spend her entire
career as a writer without really
mentioning the Napoleonic Wars which
would have to get exactly that time the
only reason soldiers ever show up and
Jane Austen is because they look nice in
uniform know the uniforms are always
clean you know they don't have blood on
them and that's not because she's
ducking something it's not because she's
avoiding some issue it's because she is
able to fully explain the lives of her
characters without recourse to the
public sphere you know it's not an
important factor in why her character
stories work out as they do now it seems
to me that that distance between the
public and the private has all but
disappeared and 9/11 is an example of
that you know the public smashes into
the private you know with incredible
force and and reverberations that we all
still feel so and that's in a way the
story of the doctrine it's about what
happens when the public world smashes
into private life you know how do people
deal with that you know survive it not
survive it what does it do to them you
know and that's that's an eternal
subject and by no means the first
writers are treated and I certainly
won't be the last you know but I think
it's it's one of the reasons why the
play and why the book you know if people
still read the book and what I think
people still see the play as no I mean
anything I'd have to add to that is that
sometimes that when you when you look at
these images that are coming on on
television actually they they are
they're slightly impersonal and they're
slightly all look there's you know
there's a whole later blanket bombing
going on and all that must have been
like Dresden and all that sort of stuff
but it's so it's actually I think one of
the great things about theater and the
one of the wonderful things about this
production is that is that you will
watch those scenes where where
individuals are actually being there
sitting there waiting for a bomb to land
on their head and kill them and then you
will know what the meaning of collateral
damages and I think that you know we
don't we don't know that however much
it's shoved in our face on telly because
it's kind of it's sanitized so much
isn't it and it's sort of it's so
distant
whereas theatre can just make it so
immediate and real and you actually see
the the kind of the repercussions on the
individual yeah there's also you know
there's a certain kind of play a certain
kind of movie in which none of the
important characters ever done you know
the people who the people who die are
always minor characters so that the
important characters could go on being
in love and have the happy ending and so
on I mean one of the reasons you know
why Hitchcock's movie psycho is so
shocking is that the wrong people get
killed you know there's the heroine I
mean Janet Leigh the biggest movie star
you know half an orange the movie she's
dead meat
you know that's not supposed to happen
she's supposed to be alive at the end so
when she is killed it's incredibly
shocking is not so much that she gets to
the scene in the shower is not the
physical scene it's who is being killed
that's shocking
and then along comes Martin balsam is
mr. safe detective the one who's going
to clear it all up and now we can just
relax and you know
uncle Martin will sort it all out for us
and then you know he's dead it's
incredibly shocking in psycho who gets
killed and it's one of the things that
happens in Midnight's Children too is
that people you deeply care about get
killed you know it's not just minor
characters it's people that over a long
period of time you've come to love you
know and then there's a war and they're
obliterated you know and and in the same
way as salim feels the loss of that
beloved family you know in a way so does
the audience because they've lived with
these people and suddenly bang you know
so important people died in a war you
know it's not just people you don't
really know it's the people you really
care about
and that's what a play could make you
feel okay we have time probably for very
few questions I'll repeat the question
so that everyone can hear him yes
okay the question is what is the
contribution of the dramaturg in this
particular production language it's as I
say it was a really genuine
collaboration of equals it was it
actually was I couldn't say which of the
three of us did more or less you know I
mean yes there was a starting point
which was subscripts I've written before
but those were scripts which if you read
them there they're actually very
substantially different to the play
script as performed it was a starting
point that's all and you know we made it
together I mean like it's I I don't
think in a way Simon acted more as a
dramaturg and less as a as an adapter
you know we just it was a script that
the three of us made together with
different perspectives
I mean Simon's editorial background if
you like Tim's staging background and my
background as the you know maker of the
original thing but we just did it
together I really think it was a you
know exact I mean we really became a
collective entity well you wrote some
stuff
I'm going to tell you which all the good
lines and the good gags interesting
thing as well is that Salman I mean was
tweeted with far too much respect for a
writer if we could just get this clear
here he was allowed into rehearsals and
he was there for about the second half
of rehearsals he was there virtually
every day actually and giving notes to
the actors which is which was fantastic
and so actually he kind of exceeded his
brief as well and I think Salmons right
that kind of all that all the roles sort
of overlapped really and it's got
something to do with this is one of the
reasons why I wanted to work with Tim
again because of the way in which I had
watched him make the Haroon production
that he lets everybody into the process
no he's not he's not one of those
directors who says you know listen to me
and shut up you know but even the actors
so the actors brought regularly brought
suggestions for how to do a scene you
know how character might might move in a
certain scene how they might say a
certain line you know how you could do a
piece of action and you know we we tried
out things that also everybody was
putting in the part we would try them
out sometimes it would work sometimes it
wouldn't work sometimes it would lead to
another thing you know that somebody
else would think oh but it's this this
process of very collaborative theater
making that the Tim revels in the way it
is that is very good at which which gave
us all the space to work in that way so
that in a way became unimportant to have
roles you know when the actors keep
trying to tell me I should get on stage
four of the production's
but I'm so far resisted that temptation
they say you'd come on to the crowd see
nobody'll notice you know I'm still
there still twisting my arm so who knows
yes are there other novels of Salman
Rushdie's that would make transition to
this stage well you know I really don't
know and truthfully if you'd asked
people at Midnight's Children I'd have
been skeptical you know see it was it is
just something that has evolved I don't
particularly I'm not particularly
thinking about doing any anything with
any of the other novels know if somebody
else wants to I listen I'm not sure that
I'd want to not necessarily want to do
the adaptation myself you know I mean I
I don't know I mean I really this
happened because it happened it happened
in a kind of ad hoc way and then it
worked out and we liked it you know but
there was no project to put my books on
the stage and on the whole if you'd
asked me if I wanted to get back into
the process of looking at a book that I
published 22 years ago I'd have thought
on the whole probably not you know but
in fact I had a really great time doing
it to my great surprise you know because
I thought it would be like a chore and
it ended up being a pleasure and part of
that has to do with you know the just a
change of pace of being somebody who
normally sits in a Roman does it by
himself and suddenly has to work with
you know 20 actors and collaborators and
designers and etc and just to be a part
of that probe that collective act it's
very unusual for me you know so that was
just great fun but no I don't you know I
mean I just I did it did make me feel
that maybe I might write you know a real
play I mean a play that doesn't have a
previous previous version in prose but I
don't have an idea
so if you've got one but it also gave
the screenplay story a happy ending
yeah so that it wasn't wasted work yeah
I did not see this but it feels very
good uh yes in the back yes young woman
yes yes oh thank you thank you
huh I mean I think obviously a lot of it
just comes out of what the sensibility
of the writer is that I've always as a
writer being very interested in movies
you know I mean I grew up in a movie
town you know it was it was difficult to
grow up in Bombay and not be interested
in movies you know because they're all
around you and they're noisy and vulgar
gene sexy you know and I had various
some members of my family who were
involved in Bombay
film industry in various ways so you
know so it was just a something that I
just naturally grew up knowing about and
so I think mostly it has to do with my
interests you know and then but you the
characters you make are also created out
of your interests so if there's some
overlap there it's not it's not
surprising you know and I think there's
a second for me I came to England to go
to boarding school and then to college
in the mid-60s and that was as it turns
out that period from period from about
1955 to about 1975 in the history of the
sound cinema is probably the last time
that Hollywood lost control of world
cinema both in terms of production and
distribution and in that period as a
result you have one of the well the
great classic period of a sound cinema
in the period of the French New Wave the
Italian New Wave everywhere you looked
you know Poland njv de Sweden Ingmar
Bergman India satrajit Rea Japan Akira
Kurosawa Hungary McMurphy ancho you know
wherever you look genius you know and
and it's amazing hard to describe what
it was like when those were the new
movies you know when you went to the
movie and this week it was Fellini's
eight and a half and the next week it
was God's pure love for the week after
that it was true for his regime the week
after that it was Bergman's the seventh
seal the other films which are now the
great classics of the cinema coming out
week after week after week as new movies
you know that was educational to me in
those days more than anything I was
getting out of books you know so so I've
always been I mean some people don't
like my writing say that it's too visual
people who do like my writing say it's
visual so you know so so this is this is
the problem of writing is that you know
your strengths are your weaknesses yes
bless you
this one yeah you know I was that
probably the part of the story that I
was least involved in that Simon can
speak to a bit more is the actual
specific casting because although I was
being kept informed about who was being
considered and who was being cast and
obviously it was invited to comment on
that it's on most of the time that the
casting was happening I was here in New
York and the casting was happening in
London so so in in some detailed way I
wasn't very involved in the in the
choices of the actors although I knew
who was be cast the one exceptions that
being the lead actor Zubin Varla who at
a very very early point long before we
had a finished script I mean read even
made a first draft script both Simon and
Tim who knew about him because he's you
know has a distinguished Shakespearean
past where he's played Romeo he's played
Caliban in The Tempest you know within
last season so he's a and we all felt
that we needed a very an actor with
great stagecraft to play that role he's
never offstage essentially for three
hours they both strongly felt that he
would be a very strong contender for the
role of the lead character and we did it
at that point we were able to do a table
reading where with a kind of group of
actors some of whom were in the play
some of them not but Zubin was there and
read the the central character on that
day and by the end of that day it was
quite clear to me if he said obvious
have to have him you know so so that was
it was one of the things that made this
easy was that we found our lead actor
straight away with no problem
way before we even had a finalized
script but really in terms of hands-on
involvement in casting that's about all
I did I don't know what do you want no I
mean the costly of selling obviously is
the most important piece of casting
because technically or actually he is
anglo-indian the character so although
you're working with a company that I
mean 18 out of 20 are British well not
actually 18 out of 20 are Asian most of
whom were British Asian actors you do
have to make a decision about selling
about where the do cast someone of mixed
race or source or some or somebody who
is just Asian and zubrin's but
a particular quality partly cuz he's
Parsi Indian but also because he's never
ever played an Asian role before he's
never played the the shopkeeper on the
corner in the in the soap operas on
telly which is what a lot of Asian
actors kind of get denigrated terrible
were they haven't spread but on the
classical stage he'd always played the
great roles despite or because of who he
was in terms of the rest of the casting
it was very interesting that there are a
couple of actors who some of whom who've
never acted on stage before but but have
do have a lot of experience in in film
and television but some of whom actually
have a bigger career in India than they
than they do in England and that was
very interesting because that was
another flavor in the rehearsal room
there's also the wonderful thing is the
one there's one token whitey in it and
he actually is Greek as well so
wonderful kind of double-barreled in
Alexei K Campbell but yes she comes from
Athens and it's a fabulous kind of
casting and we do have one actress that
she that Tim and I had worked with
before
who serene serene serene sabha who plays
Mary prera the the nurse is Lebanese but
actually one of the actresses Sarita
Kumar who plays poverty in which is the
only one who is left over from when Tim
and I did her in the sea of stories in
which four years ago she played the role
of blabbermouth in her room and I think
she's you know she's a very technically
proficient actress and has matured
wonderfully well and gives it at one of
them which one of the most powerful
performance I think in the cast so in
some cases we had that kind of
familiarity people we'd worked with
before and so on that
I mean I think in many ways for me one
of the pleasures of looking at it is
that some of the actors who were the
least experienced when we cast the
youngest least experienced people in the
cast to see how they've grown into it
evolved into it and now you know giving
them turning in I mean really stellar
performances I think you know even
though as I was saying in some cases
it's their first time on a stage we're
going to need to stop is there any one
thing you want to say as as we close to
what is probably going to be a potential
audience for you in the evening at the
Apollo no buy tickets tell your friends
yeah and if you don't like it don't tell
anyone especially if you're from the
press um thank you very much Salman
Rushdie and Simon Reid and thank you for
coming